Roger are thousand 1984 I F
international public affairs 1985 am ia
international public affairs the desire
to make the world a better place is the
unifying theme that extends to all the
students at ciba my experience in the
international fellows program was really
interesting because we had students from
the business school the law school of
the school of journalism and seba and we
would basically confront issues of
interest in the world at that time but
we'd all approach them from different
perspective I was elected
editor-in-chief of the journal of
international affairs I was able to
interview Kim dae-jung who was at that
time an opposition leader in South Korea
who had survived imprisonment torture by
the KCIA at the time and went on to
become person the country and ultimately
win a Nobel Prize I think my my
affiliation as an alumnus is strongest
with sepa in part because I think I can
have the biggest impact here the most
meaningful experience I had as a super
lump was hoping to really conceive and
organize the school 60th anniversary
celebration I had two conditions I said
you can't ask people for money other
than to cover the cost of the event and
it can't be another cheese cube into
thick type of occasion and asked do we
have to really do it 1st grade with the
help from the school which really did
the hard work of executing on the vision
we had a three-day extravaganza that was
really unique and I think very well
received by super alumni launched the
school into a new era of alumni
relations which continued to this day so
just to see all the students have put so
much work into their studies and to see
how happy they were and no matter how
hard it rained I couldn't put a damper
on their spirits so it was really a
special thing to be a part of that was I
surprised yeah I was surprised in fact I
nominated somebody else so I didn't
expect to be recipient myself